Hey Youtubers it's Charlie. This is going to
be my Arrow Episode 17 video
I know there are a lot of  questions about the big
WTFs, so I'll try to start with that
stuff first before I do top five moments
just careful for spoilers in case you
haven't seen the episode yet. So the
Suicide Squad rotated its membership
Unfortunately, Deadshot looks like he's
out.  Until we see is severed head
don't assume that he's dead completely,
but I am wondering if they "fridged" the
character because they're using Deadshot
in the Suicide Squad movie.  Remember this is the comic book world
we have a Lazarus Pit, there's no such
thing as true death not that I think
that Lawton's going to end up in the Lazarus Pit
and with respect to Ray Palmer fighting
with team Arrow
just because they ended the episode on a
positive note with respect to their
relationship
I think Oliver and Ray are still gonna have
big disagreements about how each them
goes about seeking justice
Seriously did anybody count the number
times Ray said the word justice?
it makes me think the spinoff show is
going to be Justice Society.
that's a long shot though very big long
shot. okay on a top five moments fun
stuff starting with number five
Diggle and Lyla get married. Did
anybody else get flashbacks to the Green
Arrow/Black Canary wedding from the comic books?
That was so much fun. Their wedding
night kinda ended in a similar way
to what happened on the show not exactly
it is it all kinda goes to shit
in a really big WTF way. if you haven't
read it you should check out the comic
book it a lot of fun
I think I mentioned it before but even
though Oliver had a lot of funny moments
with the other big ships that he's had
on the screen like moment with Felicity
at the wedding
moments with Laurel at the wedding I
don't think that that character is
ever going to get married during the
show's run so like if Arrow gets seven
seasons
he still won't get married by season 7
there's a couple things that'll probably
never happen on Arrow
like for instance Stephen Amell said the
he's probably ever going to get to go
sleeveless. if you remember
the Smallville Green Arrow had like no
sleeves. Stephen Amell's like
"yeah they're not going to let me do that even if we move the show to LA" and
he's probably not going to get married.  Speaking of long
shots though, I do think that Batman
or Superman or even both to them will
appear on Arrow
in some capacity before ends its run, assuming it gets more than five seasons
Onto number four the Suicide Squad
rides again
it was a nice moment in the limo but the
big reveal though is Cupid joining the
team
Amy Gumenik - you may remember her from Supernatural.  I think it's her time on
Arrow now that
everyone's going to remember for. I'd
expect now the Deadshot has been cycled
out to the team
she's probably going to take his place
so expect her to show up the next time
the Suicide Squad shows up
she's also kind of a pseudo replacement
for Harley Quinn. I think the minute
warner brothers put a Suicide Squad
movie
on the books just certain top-tier
characters- A-List characters - became
off limits but a TV show. Harley Quinn
being the biggest one
There's really no awesome explanation as to
why the TV shows
and why the movies can't do the same
characters and just do their own
versions of each
mostly I think Warner Brothers is
worried that the TV show - like having them
around on the TV show too much
will dilute the brand thinking of said
characters like Harley Quinn as brands in
and of themselves
I know it sounds stupid and it is stupid
but that's okay just give them more
opportunity to focus on the characters
they already have
so if you really like Cupid, we will be
seeing more Cupid in the future
on number three Hail Hydra, Fake Arrows
Kill one, two rise in its place, which is funny
because I actually just got done making
agency SHIELD video like right before Arrow started tonight
we know as the audience that its Ra's al Ghul who's leading all these people
around
the keep referring to it like it's one
imposter like it's one person
I think when they say there's an
imposter they're referring to the
person that is leading
all the imposters but if there's any
confusion team Arrow figures it out
right away
they know exactly what's going on there
like a clearly this is Ra's al Ghul
trying to entice me to take his offer
I'm always interested to see which WTF
plot points
that the narrative just speeds over the
people just figure out right away
and which things become a big mystery
that have to be solved over a couple
episodes
Ray Palmer learning Oliver is the Arrow is
another good example that
Onto Number 2 - Ray Palmer verses Oliver
I like the way they trap Felicity in the
middle of this without going too crazy
on her
both ran all over just like super
surprise that Felicity has been keeping
such a giant secret from each in them
but what's going on here is is they'd
just be don't want you to think that Ray
Palmer is going to be fighting
Oliver for the rest of the season. yes,
they will continue to have
really big disagreements about crime
fighting style they just don't want you
to think that they're going to be
working against each other
yes I do think there will be an Atom
team up with a team Arrow before he goes
off in a spinoff
definitely before the finale.  Team Arrow itself is gonna change quite a bit
I don't think that
Ray Palmer is ever gonna officially be a
member of Team Arrow I do think he'll be
inside the Arrow cave at some point
But Marc Guggenheim explained that his
character is going to develop
apart from the Arrow characters. the
spin-off i think is the big reason for
that
They just wanna show that this character can exist on his own
which is funny because the spinoff
shows gonna be a team up show so none of
the characters on the show are gonna be
completely by themselves
I know a lot of people be asking about the
way Oliver took down the Atom
so I think I think the reason that he
was able to do it so quickly
is because the Atom is so inexperienced it's like, yes, he has a badass
suit but if you remember Iron Man when he first wore his suit, he was a pretty
shitty superhero
I think by the time the spinoff show
starts by the time the pilot picks up
he'll be just as bad as everyone else
but until then his body will continue to
be bruised as he said in the episode, I thought that was pretty funny
make ego and my body are both very
bruised. really that whole fight scene
between Arrow and the Atom
was just meant to say chill bro for both
on the same side here
And, my number one WTF moment of course, Maseo kills the Mayor
its gonna spark a manhunt for the Arrow - a lot happened in that last scene so
here's what's going on
Ray Palmer and Laurel will still continue
to think that Oliver is innocent, he's being
framed
so they know instantly whoever's
masquerading as the Arrow, killed the
mayor
Quentin however does not - he still thinks
that the Arrow has gone bad
so he's gonna lead a task force to hunt
him down that's what next episode going
to be about
it's called Public Enemy - The Arrow becomes public enemy number one
episode 19 is the one that everyone
should be worried about that supposedly
the episode when one of the characters
is going to die
there are so many warning signs for so many different characters right now
I'd say the people at the top of my list are Roy, Quentin,
and now Diggle - I know a lot of people were wondering if Lyla was gonna die because
what happened with the Suicide Squad
plot
I'm kinda glad she didn't but obviously
them trying to quit both the teams
is not going to go well.   interesting that Diggle did not mention that in his last
meeting with Oliver
They toasted Deadshot but they didn't
talk at all about Diggle leaving the team
episode 19 is titled Broken Arrow that
could be
when Diggle tries to leave the team but
here's my big question for you guys
how do you wanna see the Atom work with
team Arrow before the end of the season
really when I like to see is is like a
crowd scene where the Atom uses
Arc blaster to take out a buncha people
while Oliver handles Ra's al Ghul
did anyone notice how much Oliver's been
training with the sword?
In each of the last couple episodes there's
been a scene where Oliver is practicing
with his sword
I think that is one remind us that he's
going to have a rematch so to speak with
Ra's al Ghul before the end of the season
and speaking a rematches, Laurel said that she has a new trainer that's been roughing her
up
a female trainer. does anyone else think
that might be Thea?
I don't if they're bringing any new characters on the show that's just why I say that
they haven't announced any other big comic book characters they've cast, and of all
the females on the show that could help
train Laurel
I think Thea's at the top of the list. I
think I already mentioned  most of the Easter eggs, you know
Green Arrow/Black Canary wedding was the biggest one
and just because Deadshot is dead on the
TV show right now doesn't mean he's dead
forever
although I do like the hive shutout
likey flashes back I'm actually
wondering if
Emily Kinney's character on the Flash in
episode 18
is going to be part of Hive - it just seems
that they're developing
the Hive storyline and that's gonna be
like a season 4  thing. I really do
feel like Hive
is going to be where the big bad comes
from in season 4
like the place they originate from so
next week episode 18 Public Enemy be
sure to subscribe to my video
I'm doing a Q&A for the flash and arrow this week I know there's tons of questions about
time travel a lot of Flash stuff going on
as well as what's going on with the
Ra's al Ghul League of Assassins storyline on Arrow, so be sure to leave all your
questions
While you guys wait for that, in case you guys haven't seen it, I just
posted by Agents of Shield
video for this week you can click
here to watch that
learn all about like some teases for
Captain America's Civil War some seeds
being lain for like Shield versus Shield stuff
and you can click here for this week's
episode of the Flash. thank you so much
watching everybody
let's high five - I'll see you tomorrow.